I will do reading and writing uh so I'll  I'm usually working on a book at any  given time uh or if you shut off the the  rest of the world yes so I put some  music in my ears usually Brahms or Bach  uh sometimes Beethoven or Mozart it's  those four those are on rotation no rap  no rap no rap despite my extraordinary  rendition of whap yeah I'm not in fact  around you still do you still hate rap  um the song it's uh I will say I do not  think that it is the peak of Western  civilized art okay I I don't think that  100 years from now people will be gluing  their faces to a whap and protest at the  environment but uh Brahms and the rest  will be still around yes I would assume  if people still have a functioning  prefrontal cortex and any sort of wrong  words from Ben Shapiro